the way I like to think about it is I
spent my third first 24 years on
retirement oh no actually 30 and then so
I got a pretty much work till I die now
[Laughter]
yeah now you're in [ __ ] prison and
you I mean so when did you find out how
long you're gonna stay in the county now
so I get a rain this what I was talking
about earlier get a rain I think I get a
court date in like two months you have a
lawyer no okay so this is the part I was
telling about so my mom was like do you
want a lawyer
and I was like no they got me like dead
to right just oh I'm guilty there's no
way there's no fight in it that's great
the [ __ ] so I was like I'll just stick
with a public defender like don't waste
the money because it's a it's like a
like the higher your felony is like
pretty much that's how much the lawyers
gonna charge you that much more right
it's been a deal so I go to court the
first day and usually like it's it's
usually nothing it's usually a waste of
fun just as you another day it's yeah
pretty much so you usually do that for
like a few times before they come at you
with an offer like where the state will
come with you like well plead guilty
today and get this many years or do
whatever pension and all that [ __ ] so
the first day I walk into court I even
told my parents I haven't told everybody
don't come because it's not it's gonna
be a waste of time so I go in there and
they're like all right Jake Jane state
of Florida versus Jake James so it lists
all my charges the state sits there and
I mean yeah it looks super bad on
[ __ ] paper but they were like they're
going back to when I'm 16 for a smoking
of tobacco citation Wow and like they're
just they're just trying to make me look
like I [ __ ] kill babies right thank
you as bad as they can yeah yeah so um
so judges like art state what do you
want to do let's set this for trial next
month on blah blah blah date
judge goes we already have a trial set
for the afternoon state goes oh that's
fine the alternative that day for the
day that they said that they scheduled
the like a preacher it was like okay so
they scheduled the trial for they told
me to take 15 years today or if I don't
they're scheduling trial for next month
on this date so that date the judge
says we already have a trial set in the
afternoon State goes oh don't worry this
will take like a half an hour and when
he loses were giving him 35 years so I'm
like okay um oh this sucks well I guess
we're setting it for trial so I went
back I went back to the pod so I could
use the phone and I called my mom I was
like we got to get a lawyer I'm gonna be
gone forever you know what I mean
because I'm 24 years old I think 30
years old is a senior citizen there yeah
yeah so I was like jesus [ __ ] christ
dude so we get the lawyer and it's 60
but I get out of here yeah so it would
mean it was a good lawyer so we we kept
pushing it back they kept they kept
wanting me to take 15 years like every
month kind of when I went to court and I
mean just just hearing the 15 years for
so long yeah but there was a lot of [ __ ]
that happened in between I I was I've
trapped probably okay so the the max
part of the jail and pinellas is so like
overcrowded that you sleep on these
boats like new guys that would come in
you sleep on these boats and they don't
[ __ ] take your beds all you [ __ ]
tough guys out there like that you just
[ __ ] do whatever so I'm out in this
damn room so it's like it's all cells
and yeah so it's supposed to be
everybody's in their cell at night from
I think like from 11:00 to 5:00 or
something like that
all right at night yeah but I'm in the
day room there's no room for anybody
there's people out in the day room and
I'm I'm walking around it's like it's
probably like 1:00 2:00 in the morning
I'm kind of walking around I'm kind of
pissed
the guards telling me to lay down I keep
telling them [ __ ] you
I was like come in here and make me
[ __ ] lay down pretty much so they
[ __ ] take me out of that cell and
they put me in a bigger one and I do the
same thing I'm like well I'm not [ __ ]
going in a Cell [ __ ] you I'm like come
in here make me [ __ ] go in the cell
yeah so but then I remember one of my
buddies I grew up with over in Laura go
he odd he goes Jake get your dumb ass in
this [ __ ] cell like I grew up with
him like in middle school she liked that
so I'm like all right cool
so uh another time like they because
they just [ __ ] with you man like there
pieces of [ __ ] do you there you know
what I mean they just they live some of
them lived oh [ __ ] with you
yeah you know what I mean so so like
it's just like you kind of just have
enough dude and it's like you're so
stressed out like I'm gonna get em I'm
gonna get like I'm not it's like it's
hard it's hard to be like okay yeah I'm
gonna here I'm gonna do 15 years yeah
let me say this [ __ ] piece of paper
yeah I mean it's hard it's it's like
it's really [ __ ] when you're younger
you only mean so this one time I tried
to fight a cop he did he was he was
acting like he wanted to fight and then
I tried and then he's kind of backed off
hit the panic button
uh-huh they they a lot of weapons don't
they no they only have mace they have
mason taser guns
so we we'd act really [ __ ] tough
until they pulled the tasers out well
they still the ones that focus treat you
with the prongs you're like yeah where
do you want me lay down like that and
then just so like that I would go to
confinement get out and then this one
time they were because you have lockdown
at shift change so like in max there was
there was two shifts it was twelve hour
shifts so before his shift
what are you okay so when you say man
what does that mean the the maximum
security part of the jail okay kind of
deal see you are like in a prison no
this is this is still County Jail okay
guys so you're you're in county jail
until you get sentenced got kind of deal
so you're super [ __ ] guilty until
you're proven guilty yeah yeah you know
what I mean like they take everything
away like innocent till proven guilty is
[ __ ] [ __ ] pressure yeah they take
they strip everything [ __ ] away from
you and then so I and they true they
treat you like [ __ ] animals so that's
how [ __ ] [ __ ] act in there
right like [ __ ] just like just strip
down like [ __ ] cavemen so I shift
change happens they're supposed to count
they count make sure everybody's still
there that's supposed to be there and
then they leave but they close the cells
and then that shut all the TVs
everything off so you can't be [ __ ] and
it's usually like 30 40 minutes
somewhere in there yeah in the in the
county but these month these [ __ ]
kept us in there for like two hours so I
felt can get everybody [ __ ] riled up
we're [ __ ] we're throwing like
because it's all try to explain how
these [ __ ]
there's small [ __ ] rooms like a day
room and then you got the cells on the
back so and it's all like plexiglass
windows so they can see you so we start
hanging sheets like over the bars so
where they can't see us and we're
throwing or throwing like wet paper
table toilet paper [ __ ] wads at the
windows we're just like chunking [ __ ]
and they get me and like two other dudes
for like inciting a riot so they put me
on this [ __ ] coat that's administrative
segregation to where they could put you
in confinement for however long they
want yeah with no because usually if you
get in trouble you get it's like a
[ __ ] principal referral yeah and then
you go to your the principal and they
tell you okay well you whatever you do
you get thirty days down and down in
[ __ ] confinement but with this [ __ ]
it's however long they [ __ ] want to
keep you down there Wow
so like a solitary yeah by yourself um
well the way the county jail was it was
it's like another big pod but like
you're in a cell by yourself right
so it's just like you and a bunch of
other [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] just like
you do [ __ ] I've tried to [ __ ] it
past the time and it sucks so they had
they brought me down and least [ __ ]
these [ __ ] hated me they they
handcuffed me they put they like they
put all your [ __ ] in a trash bag like
all your [ __ ] commissary where the
[ __ ] you have these Scott they squirted
like all my shampoo all over all my [ __ ]
in the bag just kind of like shook it up
they uh their guy walks me down and the
cells open and there's [ __ ] [ __ ] all
over this [ __ ] cell and I go you're
not [ __ ] putting me in there
and he goes oh we'll send somebody down
here to clean it up it's like I don't I
know that's a [ __ ] lie you you're not
gonna [ __ ] trick me I'm not going
that so so I got my feet like against
the [ __ ] doorway that cell yeah
pushing back at him I'm not going
[ __ ] in here dude like I'm ready to
[ __ ] right not going this fries out
you're gonna fight and he's trying to
he's trying to like get me to come in
there just so he throw me in a [ __ ]
so full of [ __ ] right little [ __ ] like
there's [ __ ] all over the walls and all
over everything that because there's a
lot of crazy [ __ ] yeah right
right and that's a whole nother [ __ ]
story that's so [ __ ] gross yeah so uh
so he finally gives in it puts me in a
normal cell so I mean as you're just
like Jonah in this [ __ ]
finding your leg okay this is cool
you're pretty much just like jerking off
and doing push-ups that's it that's it
and do some lunges for how long yeah how
long do they give you I was I was in
there well that was like towards the end
right before I got sent so I think I did
a little over a month in there okay and
then but that I mean that shit's gross
Oh like they [ __ ] whip up [ __ ] with
piss in a cup and like if you're [ __ ]
the dude like next to you doesn't he
gets mad at you for some [ __ ] reason
cuz I remember one day he was I saw
something doing that and then I saw him
seen him throw this Cup in this guy's
cell like because you can kind of
because it's kind of like an L kind of
deal
so like this guy in this cell got mad at
this guy yeah yeah seen him throws like
that and I was like that's weird why
would he throw coffee in his cell oh
yeah and then they send these
[ __ ] over like bop bug it's
like other inmates are called trustees
like the [ __ ] good dudes yeah
whatever
so and then they just dump like hot
soapy water so the [ __ ] shitty soap
water just runs into everybody's cells
so you're just like like oh oh my just
like on top of your bunk just like man I
should have made way better life choices
like that was probably the first time in
my life where I was like you know what
now I know exactly what my parents were
talking about
[Laughter]